vamos a multiplicar 40 por 70 tenemos 40
veces el número 70 y podríamos escribir
el número 70 40 veces y después sumarlos
pero realmente es mucho trabajo hacer
esto tiene que haber una forma más
rápida otra forma de hacerlo es seguir
haciendo multiplicaciones pero ver si
podemos descomponer estos números este
40 y este 70 descomponer los de manera
que nos queden cantidades o números que
sean más sencillos de multiplicar para
mí multiplicar por 10 es lo más sencillo
porque conozco el patrón de agregar un 0
al número original así que vamos a
descomponer al 40 en 4 veces 10 4 por 10
y 40 son equivalentes son lo mismo por
lo que puedo reemplazar este 40 por el 4
por 10 y voy a hacer lo mismo con el 70
lo voy a descomponer como 7 por 10 estas
dos expresiones 40 por 74 por 10
7 x 10 son iguales son equivalentes por
lo que tendrán la misma solución pero
para mí es más sencillo trabajar con la
expresión de aquí abajo por estas
multiplicaciones por 10 así que voy a
resolver esta sabiendo que voy a obtener
la misma solución que la de aquí arriba
lo que podemos hacer es reacomodar estos
números para seguir facilitando nuestra
multiplicación porque en la
multiplicación no importa el orden de
los factores puedo tener 5 por 2 y esto
va a ser igual a 2 por 5 ambos son igual
a 10 5 veces 2 o 2 veces 5 es lo mismo
por lo que podemos cambiar el orden sin
cambiar la respuesta voy a cambiar aquí
el orden pero no voy a cambiar la
solución aquí primero voy a escribir mis
cantidades de un dígito 4 por 7 y
después voy a multiplicar mis decenas
por 10
por 10 tenemos los mismos factores los
mismos números solo hemos cambiado el
orden en el que los escribimos
resolvemos esto 4 por 7 es 28 y tenemos
28 por 10 y de nuevo por 10 y el patrón
que conocemos al multiplicar por 10 es
que cuando multiplicamos un número
entero como 28 por 10 simplemente le
vamos a agregar un 0 al final ya que 28
por 10 es igual a 28 decenas o lo que es
lo mismo 280 ya multiplicamos 28 por 10
y ahora lo vamos a multiplicar de nuevo
por 10 es decir le vamos a agregar otro
0 al final cada vez que multiplicamos
por 10 vamos a agregar un 0 al final así
que si multiplicamos por 10 por 10 pues
quiere decir que vamos a agregar dos
ceros al final de este número así que 28
por 10 por 10 es 28 centenas lo que
significa que mi expresión original
también va a ser igual a 28 centenas
o 2800 veamos otro ejemplo en donde
estamos multiplicando decenas
ahora vamos a multiplicar 90 por 30 y lo
primero que vamos a hacer es descomponer
estos números de manera que me queden
las decenas por separado ya que para mí
las escenas son más fáciles de
multiplicar por separado 90 lo
descompongo como 9 por 10 y 30 me va a
quedar 3 por 10 las expresiones son
equivalentes simplemente las escribimos
de forma diferente y ahora vamos a
reacomodar estos números así que
pongamos primero a nuestros números de
un dígito 9 por 3 y luego ponemos los
números de 2 dígitos por 10 por 10 ya
que necesitamos tener los mismos números
que teníamos aquí arriba aún cuando sólo
les cambiamos el orden tenemos el 9
tenemos el 3 tenemos este 10 y tenemos
este otro 10 y ahora si multiplicamos 9
por 3 es 27 27 por 10
ser 27 decenas y 270 y 272 170 decenas o
2700 con el cero al final regresamos a
la pregunta original noventa por treinta
va a ser igual a 27 centenas o 270
decenas o 2700